so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host Carl small and today we're talking
about Dr Harley Harvey krippin a
notorious transatlantic murder mystery
and I should note that as always this
video is based on original script
submitted To Us by a member of our
writing team that being Ru Alexander
follow them on the social media links
below if they provide them for us
otherwise let's get to
it at his trial hly Harvey crippin was
described as one of the most dangerous
and remarkable men to have lived this
century and a compelling and masterful
personality you feared neither God nor
man the people who knew crippin though
described him in a completely different
way they referred to crippin as being as
docile as a kitten a humble un assuming
little man you would not have believed
could kill a mouse those were the two
opposites of Dr Crippen a man who
appeared to be a real life Dr G and Mr
Hy so which of these two men was cripper
was he the cunning and remorseless
psychopath who successfully dawned the
guise of a gentle henek husband and
fooled all those around him or was he
truly innocent and himself became the
victim of a miscarriage of Justice why
don't you ruminate about that as we
discuss his
life Hy Harvey krippin was born on
September 11th 1862 in Coldwater
Michigan the only child of a man named
myON Augustus krippin and his wife
andessa Skinner young Hy grew up in a
privileged household his grandfather
father fio crippin was a Pioneer who
settled in cold water back when it was
just a handful of log cabins but being
situated at the junction between the
Coldwater River and the Chicago turnp
the little settlement saw a lot of
activity from loggers and fur trappers
who passed that way to reach the
Northern woods fio opened a general
store to supply all the passes by and it
quickly flourished by the time Hy's
father myON inherited the business the
crippin were already prosperous and
lived in the biggest house in town
despite the store being responsible for
the family's affluence Hy had no desire
take it over when he was old enough
instead from a young age he looked up to
his uncle Bradley who served as a family
doctor for pretty much all of cold water
he wasn't much of a surprise then that
when he grew up Hoy crippin studied
medicine well sort of he studied
Homeopathy first in his native Michigan
and then in London for a spell and
finally graduated from the homeopathic
Hospital College in Cleveland Ohio in
1884 after graduation it was time for Dr
krippin to find himself a job he worked
in Detroit for a spell working as an
assistant to a Dr Porter before going to
New York where he studied the year at
the Opthalmic hospital and emerged
qualified as an ear and eye specialist
during that time he met and fell in love
with another student named Charlotte
Jane Bell and a couple got married in
December 1887 the following year the doc
and his new wife moved to San Diego
California where he opened his practice
this was pretty close to crippin's
parents who relocated to California in
Los Angeles during the 1870s but the
move was not permanent for whatever
reason krippin just did not seem to be
the kind of guy to stay in one place for
too long and just a few years later he
left San Diego and went to Salt Lake
City Utah by that point charot had given
birth to their son Harley Otto and was
already pregnant with their second child
when she died suddenly of apexi and
there was never any reason to suspect
that her death was anything but natural
but given who her husband was and later
what he became Infamous for it was
natural for people to assume that maybe
her husband had you know helped helped
Shuffle her off this Mortal coil now a
widower with a three-year-old son
crippin resorted to his default course
of action moving away feeling that he
was more of a career guy than a parental
type he sent his kid off to live with
his parents and moved to New New York
City where he became a doctor's
assistant and also met the first woman
who would change his life forever so I'm
interrupting this video with a message
from today's sponsor but don't worry
because I'm talking about the sponsor
that means we get an appearance from
business anti year I am so happy that we
decided to just make this stuffed antia
a mascot for the sponsorship I really
like just petting this an it's a very
soothing thing but today's sponsor is
nordvpn and I'd like to open with a
story are you ready Brad Denisha you
wondering Brad Anisha who are these guys
like you were behind the scenes right we
do you do yes so that's you're in here
behind the scenes to help me tell the
audience today about today's sponsor and
I've got a story so it's getting near
Christmas isn't it and I've ordered a
lot of presents from are we allowed to
say the name like that company that
sells everything now and like many
people my email inbox was just cluttered
with messages of like this thing's been
delivered this thing's been yeah I know
yeah I know yeah I know I'm in I've
never not been more in and then I
noticed a text message that said we
missed your delivery today and I was
like okay well I was in the most in I've
ever been ever but maybe I did miss
something CU I've got a lot of stuff on
order and when I clicked that I did the
thing that you're supposed to do when
you see something like that you click
where the email was from and it wasn't
from the big company that owns
everything it was from bunch of numers
at gives a hell.com and I realized
that's a fishing scam and I'd like to
consider myself like you know a seasoned
user of the internet and I almost fell
for that thankfully if you know you want
to avoid stuff like if you want peace of
mind nordvpn is there to help you out so
tell me more about our sponsor today
nordvpn as I flick my
Snoop so if people are unaware of VPN
stands for virtual private Network I've
always wondered that I've actually never
looked this up like say VPN is just a
word right it's like oh yeah virtual
private Network that makes so much sense
and what does a virtual private Network
do when it's at home so basically it
hides your online
activity and here's the thing though
like how many devices can I protect at
once um six devices okay so I'm like an
online content creator so I'm like a
very edge used case let's see how many
devices I have Within Reach right now so
I've got my laptop I have my phone I
have my work computer I have my other
laptops in the other room so that's four
because I've got I've got a home laptop
as well I have my non- business phone so
that's five and I actually now year then
I've got my other editing PC so start
six that sck I could protect all of my
and I'm like a very edge use case so
even in like the most extreme cases
someone with so many devices all of them
would be protected yeah one of the good
features about nordvpn as well is their
threat protection yes cuz you know when
you're online you're constantly being
threatened Oh you mean abstract okay it
blocks trackers M I think just blocks
like weirdos on Twitter from telling me
to um uh it's the threat tracker just
this little and also it scans files that
you're downloading to make sure they're
safe which is exceptionally useful in
this day and age given that virtually
all businesses conducted online now or
at least it should be because it's
easier and safer for everybody but
downloading Mass amounts of files always
lead you open to attack of some kind and
the fact that you can have again that
peace of mind check out nordvpn and get
a 4mon extra on a 2-year plan by going
to www. nordvpn.com
sbio it's risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money back guarantee hey that
rhymes
back in the Big Apple krippin found work
with a certain Dr Jeffrey and it was in
his office that krippin first laid eyes
on a 19-year-old woman named Kora Turner
kora's real name was kunig gundi makami
the daughter of a Russian polish father
and a German mother but she had
aspirations of becoming a big singing
star so obviously she needed a catchier
stage name that was easier to say and
pronounce and spell so later on she'll
perform under the name Bell elore but
we'll just keep calling her cor for the
sake of Simplicity crippin fell for her
the moment he saw her but he had some
competition at the time cor returner was
the Mistress of a married stove
manufacturer named Lincoln who had
rented an apartment for her and was
paying for her expenses and even some
singing lessons which as you're about to
learn she sorely sorely needed this
Lincoln guy had a lot to offer cor but
it was one thing he couldn't give her a
wedding ring and that's where krippin
had the advantage he certainly wasn't
shy about his feelings for kaora the two
started spending some time together one
day cor informed him that Lincoln wanted
her to go away with him and whether or
not this was true we cannot say but it
had the desired effects on krippin who
proposed to her on the spot they tied
the knot on September 1st 1892
unfortunately the couple was not headed
for marital bliss shortly after the
wedding cor had a medical emergency that
required a
aeromyth removal of her ovaries this
left her Baron which immediately put a
great strain on their relationship since
both of them wanted children more
relevant to the later murder
investigation though is that it also
left her with a very distinct scar but
more on that later for now though
krippin was a happily married man with a
Blushing Bride unlik Lincoln before him
he kept paying for music lessons for Cor
in the hopes that one day she might make
it big however deep down it's likely
that cripper knew the truth his wife
just wasn't that talented sure she made
some ways of the church choir but that
wasn't enough to get on a big stage
especially now she set a sight on
becoming an opera singer to make matters
worse crippin was affected by the
economic depression known as the Panic
of 1893 and he had to close his medical
practice and move in with cor's parents
maybe he was just a a crap doctor we'll
never know what he did study Homeopathy
to start with so either way he found a
new and better job selling patent
medicines for a business named mions one
of the biggest homeopathic companies in
the country even after the American
government passed the 1906 Pure Food and
Drug Act and tested some of mion's
products and showed that like almost all
quack remedies they mainly consisted of
water oils and whatever else they found
in their cupboards that day the company
still bizarrely remained profitable
crippin and Company boss James Mion had
a good working relationship for most of
the adult lives in fact years later when
krippin was on trial for murder monion
offered a large reward anyone who could
Pro that cor Turner was still alive but
for the time being Mion transferred kpon
to Philadelphia then to Toronto then
back to Philly to manage the officers
there then in 1897 monion decided it was
time to expand across the pond and sent
krippin to London to manage a new Branch
over there in Jolly Old
England initially krippen travel to
London alone cor was understandably
getting a little sick of all the moving
around and the negative impact it had on
her the itical musical career however
after a few months she did join her
husband in London with a new goal she
abandoned her dream of becoming an opera
singer in favor of a music hall singer
something which was a bit more within
the Realms of possibility and in England
Ka possessed a quality she didn't have
back home she was exotic her American
accent which was quite on Vogue at the
time immediately gave her an edge over
other performers even if her singing
wasn't up to Snuff already cor was
suffering from delusions of grandeur and
saw herself topping bills on London's
West End but her debut was a bit of a
reality check she wasn't on the west end
but at the old marrowbone Music Hall in
a mini operator called the unknown
quantity opening night was a disaster
where the audience mostly sat on their
hands while kaora sang her little heart
out the theater gave her a week's run
but afterwards decided not to renew her
contract this was a humiliating blow for
cor who placed most of the blame on her
husband well it is true that initially
krippin was against his wife performing
in music halls but eventually he did
relent and even act as their manager for
a spell and we're not sure if he
actually did anything but He's listed as
as manager in a play bill which actually
landed him in hot water with his boss
back in America you see in 1899 KP was
called back to America by Mion who got
his hands on one of those play bills and
fired him because he was concerned he
was spending too much time managing his
wife's floundering career he also didn't
want his very legitimate business to be
associated with a sedy underworld of
Music Hall performance you know his
business selling quack remedies and
snake oils to uh unsuspecting customers
once he returned to London krippin had
to look for another job he didn't have
the qualifications to practice medicine
in England so instead he act as a
consultant or manager to various
businesses that sold the same kind of
basic quack remedies as monion had
although none of these jobs lasted
particularly long and neither did the
business themselves for that matter
because again they were selling stuff
that didn't work and it's real hard to
stay in business when your product
doesn't work at the same time crippin
had to deal with a growing riff between
him and his wife at one point she told
him straight up that she didn't care for
him anymore and that she'd be an affair
with an xboxer turn Ville performer
named Bruce Miller at this point krippin
had already accepted the role of the
henpecked husband so he predictably did
what cor expected him to do absolutely
nothing he carried on just like before
at least until he met a second woman who
would change his life
forever in 1902 krippin was working as a
Consulting physician at The doet
Institute for the death and don't let
that fancy name fool you it was nothing
more than a Flim Flam designed to Griff
money out of people by selling quack
remedies by mail for various ear
ailments kryon was only there for a
couple of years but it was enough time
for him to meet Ethel Clara lve a
17-year-old typist who worked at The
Institute alongside her sister nah
eventually Nina left to get married and
Ethel climbed up the ranks a bit until
she became crippin's personal secretary
Ethel looked at crippin in a way that
his wife had not done in years with
adoration even worship sure this was
because she was still young and innocent
but to her krippin was a fancy doctor
and a distinguished older gentleman at
that pretty much the complete opposite
of her own father her no good drunk can
L for his part krippin to reciprocated
the affection admiration he received
from Ethel since he wasn't getting it at
home in the both metaphorical and
literal sense unsurprisingly their
feelings of platonic fondness for each
other turned into feelings of not so
platonic fondness and crippin resorted
to the biggest cliche in the book he
began an affair with his own secretary
by this point husband and wife now
merely tolerated one another's presence
as they both carried on Liaisons with
other people Ka was too concerned with
her own life to care about what krippin
was doing like career-wise she never
made it to a top it's not like she could
just magically become an amazing singer
overnight if she couldn't make it
through the front door of the
entertainment world she could wiggle her
way through a narrow sight passage so
the one thing Ka was good at was social
mixing even her limited standing in the
Music Hall business got her invites to a
few fancy parties and there she met and
befriended some pretty big names which
as Marie Lloyd and Lil hathon before you
knew it cor was part of their Inner
Circle and was named the fundraiser for
the Music Hall ladies Guild and this was
really the perfect position for kaora
since it allowed her to pretend that she
was a much bigger star than she truly
was thus balancing the grandness of her
dreams and ambition with the harsh
realities of her mediocre Talent this
was how the arrangement went on for a
few years but things changed in 1909 it
could be because crippin's finances were
hanging by a thread between keeping two
women one of whom had pretty expensive
taste in Furs and diamonds and investing
in a floundering Dental remedy business
called y too Specialists krippin was
flirting with bankruptcy to say the
least and it could be because Ethel was
getting sick of being the Mistress of a
married man and she wanted more for
herself and she even used a friendship
with a CO loder named John Stonehouse to
show the doctor that she had other
options and this prompted the response
she wanted from crippin who showed up
with a diamond ring presumably a firmer
commitment to their relationship or it
could also have been because Ethel got
pregnant with crippin's child and
suffered a miscarriage cor found out
about this and started spreading rumors
that Ethel had had an abortion because
she couldn't tell which one of her many
lovers was the father crippin could
handle all the abuse aimed at him
without flinching but he would not allow
the name of the woman he loved to be b
smurged or it could be a combination of
all three reasons whatever motivate
crippin he finally decided it was time
to take drastic
action on Monday January 31st Paul and
claraa martinetti joined the crippin for
dinner and a game of Wist this was done
at the assistance of Dr crippin himself
who called on his friends two times
during that day to make sure that they
would come the martinetti retired at
around 1:30 in the morning leaving cor
and the doctor alone in their house at
number 39 hrop cresant cor krippin was
never heard or seen again a few days
later krippin tendered his wife's
resignation for the Music Hall Guild and
started parading around town with Ethel
cor Show's friends got suspicious
especially when they noticed that Ethel
was wearing some of kora's diamonds and
they knew that K loved her diamonds a
lot more than she loved her husband that
she would never leave them behind and
when they asked for an explanation
krippin simply stated that his wife had
left suddenly for America and she wasn't
coming back pressed for details he
became evasive which only increased
their suspicion Lil H for and her
husband John Nash were convinced that
something was a my and they traveled all
the way to New York to find Kora there
they received a letter from England
which which said that according to
crippin his wife had died in Los Angeles
of pneumonia this wasn't a very well
thought out lie from the doctor
obviously if the couple sailed across
the ocean to ask about kaora they're not
going to skimp out on a longdistance
phone call so they called the police in
Los Angeles and were told that nobody by
the name of Ka crippin cor Turner B
Elmer or even and this is my favorite
word I've said during this video Cony
gundai makami had died there and that
settled it the couple returned to London
and Nash scheduled an appointment with a
friend of his at Scotland Yard and
informed him they believe that Dr
krippin had murdered his wife inspector
Walter du was assigned to the case
krippin had a better story lined up the
detective he confessed that he lied to
his wife's friends he did not want to
admit the humiliating truth that his
wife had left him for another man
crippin went into detail about their
unhappy marriage the Affairs hoping to
admit just enough wrongdoings to make
himself out to be a bit of a scoundrel
but not a murderer he then said that as
far as he knew cor was alive and well
presumably having traveled to Chicago to
rekindle romance with Bruce Miller who
went there a few years earlier krippin
even allowed the police to take a look
around his home and see that everything
was fine D left the house not completely
free of Suspicion but not at all
convinced that he was dealing with a
killer and at this point krippin might
have gotten away with it if he played
cool but he wasn't really the cool type
was he as we've discussed while
mentioning his backstory he was more of
a panic and do something stupid type and
when du returned the following Monday
for a follow-up interview he discovered
that crippin and Ethel lenie had flown
the coupe during the weekend so he done
what he always did and ran away and this
is what a season detective Like Walter
do would refer to as suspicious Behavior
the police decided to take a closer look
at the house 39 till drop Cresent first
they took up the garden and then the
coal seller where they struck pay dirt
and by P we mean the decomposing torso
of a woman who'd been
murdered after his initial interview
with the police crippin didn't think he
had them fo so he and ethor quickly set
sale for Brussels intending to plan
their next move there meanwhile the body
had been found and all of England was in
shock over the gruesome death the
newspapers branding Dr krippin as the
London Celler murderer and clearly they
didn't have any good headline writers in
that day following the discovery of what
was left in the body a team of London's
top pathologist and toxicologist works
out the Torso belong to a plump woman
who regularly bleached her hair this
fitted cor gin's description they also
discovered a scar on the lower abdomen
in the same place cor had had her opery
the cause of death was hene pooning a
drug that crippin had purchased a few
weeks earlier even though it wasn't part
of his regular orders for his
homeopathic remedies all the fingers
were starting to point at the doctor and
there was just one thing left to do
catch him so meanwhile kpon decided on
his course of action he and Ethel would
go to an where they were Bard the montos
and traveled to Canada they would both
disguise themselves with eff donning the
outfit of a young boy unfortunately for
the fleeing couple their ghts were not
good enough to fo the captain of the
ship Henry George Kendall just before
setting off on the trip he had read a
description of cripper and Ethel in a
news paper which speculated that Ethel
might try passing herself off as a young
boy since the Monro was a repurposed
cargo vessel it didn't have that many
passengers so the couple stood out from
the start as a result Kendall had his
Telegraph operator send the following
message to England and I quote have
strong suspicion that crippin London
seller murderer and accomplice are
amongst the saloon passengers mustache
shaved off growing beard accomplish
dressed as a boy voice Manner and build
undoubtedly a girl once he got the
message do set sale from Liverpool
the laurentic a faster ocean got him to
Canada before the montro and on July
31st the montos had stopped in St
Lawrence where the detective barded The
Vessel disguised as a pilot he
approached crippin who reacted quite
placidly and made no attempts to escape
he only stressed that Ethel knew nothing
about it and allowed himself to be taken
into custody thus marking a significant
and curious landmark in criminal history
this being the first time that wireless
telegraphy was used to catch a killer
the trial was to put it lightly a media
circus but a short one at that after 5
days of testimony the jury found cripp
and guilty in just 2 7 Minutes of
deliberations and the judge sentenced
him to death and what made things
curious is that kpon refused to plead
guilty but at the same time offered a
little resistance or explanations for
his actions even refusing certain
strategies pitched by his defense team
because they would implicate ethol Andie
if that was truly his greatest concern
then crippin got his wish Ethel was
cleared of all Chargers she moved around
for a bit and then simply faded Into
Obscurity after a brief date with infamy
do krippin protest his innocence to the
end that being November 23rd 1910 when
he was hanged from The Gallows at
Pentonville prison and thus ended one of
the most notorious murder cases in
British history although maybe not quite
in recent decades there has been renewed
Doubt cast Over crippin's guilt some say
that the scar on the Torso which is the
key piece of evidence that implicated
krippin during the trial was actually
just a skinfold others argue that if
krippin truly did murder and mutilate
his wife he could have gotten rid of a
torso the same way he disposed of the
head and limbs which were never found so
for anyone cous like they found a torso
what the head no none of that was found
just the Torso so it's argued that if he
managed to dispose of those so
thoroughly that they were never found
surely would have done the same thing
with the Torso rather than just bury it
in his basement then you have an
American team of scientists who claimed
in 2007 that DNA from the Torso did not
match that of kora's distant relatives
although not everyone is buying their
story so far the criminal case review
commission has refused to reopen the
case despite repeated calls to do so but
who knows what might happen in the
future it is possible that one of
Britain's most infamous Killers could be
exonerated although that's a story for
another time so I hope you found this
episode of biographic informative I
certainly while reading through the
scripts and if you've got any comments
or feedback or suggestions you can leave
them in the comments Below in particular
we'd like to know if there's any other
people you'd like us to cover on
biographics because there's plenty of
people out there who lived fascinating
lives that we've not gotten around to
yet and you know our writers could do
like a little push in the direction of
those people so if you got any examples
ideas stuff like that leave them Below
in the comments if you want to see more
videos like this subscribe if you like
the video leave a like and as always
like to wish everybody out there the day
that they deserve
and I think I've been saying that in
enough videos now where I can talk about
the origins of it because I've started
to notice that people say it to me now
on social media and stuff like that so
it's nice to see that it's spreading um
it's not something I came up with on my
own it was a friend of mine used to work
in a store um he was doing customer
service and he was like he had a bad day
as I think anyone who working customer
service can relate to and he was a bit
snippy um with a an older West Indian
lady and rather than like you know get
annoyed with with him she just like she
took a problem she just looked him in
the eye and just said thank you young
man have the day that you
deserve and watch out and he said just
in that moment hearing that made him
completely change his entire attitudes
so while interacting with people the
rest of the day and just like really
took it on board and I just really like
that thought of like telling people you
know you have the day that you deserve
so I've always liked that as a a sign
off so I adopted it for these videos
which I hope people appreciate or at
least take on board like I did cuz it's
just yeah
it's it's it's nice so yeah go out there
and do that cheers
[Music]
everybody